für welchen monat erwarten sie das alles
fällt das alles wieder normal wird hier
in deutschland in europa also ich glaube
es wäre vertrieb war tatsächlich ist das
impfangebot zu koppeln und von daher ist
könnte man sicherlich ab
september/oktober den bürgern sagen habe
jetzt ist es individuell verantwortung
welche maßnahmen wir für euch als
notwendig erachtet und welche maßnahmen
wir dann noch anwendet ich würde mir
sehr viel mehr freiheit für den
einzelnen wünschen aber das impfangebot
sollte stehen das ist bis ende september
spätestens oktober der fall also freedom
day aus ihrer sicht ende september herr
blume wie sehen sie sie wollen am anfang
ein konkretes datum sehen aber
vielleicht wurden sie von den klugen
argumenten von herrn gassen überzeugt
jetzt doch ein datum zu nennen
ich habe nur der sendung wahrgenommen
dass eigentlich jeder schwierigkeit man
hat ein konkretes datum zu nennen und
ich kann das auch absolut nachvollziehen
und ich halte es auch weiterhin so
kroner bekämpfung ist nicht
lotteriespiel sondern er heißt aber nina
würde reich und so wirkt ganzen tag
unter der ende september oktober
ich halte ich sehe mich auch außerstande
einen monat zu nennen wir haben einen
tag der deutschen einheit das ist der
deutsche freiheitstag aber was die
korona bekämpfung angeht wird die
geschichte von dem corona virus leider
auf andere art geschrieben
vor lauter schnarrenberger freedom day
am tag der deutschen einheit
zumindest eine idee von herrn summe also
ich würde das jetzt nicht unbedingt mit
dem tag der deutschen einheit verbinden
das ist ein freuden und freiheitstag
immer egal wie eine pandemie auch
irgendwo stattfindet aber politik muss
sich doch ehrgeizige ziele setzen
deshalb bin ich bayern kassen ja mitten
im angebot für alle und das ist jetzt ja
schon dabei sparen hat gesagt es gibt ja
jetzt schon mal ein angebot für alle
also das ist dass spätestens im mitte
september und ende september der fall ja
und dann bin ich für ein freedom day da
bin ich bayern kassen